I finally broke down and bought myself
a plasma TV
check it out I actually hung this on the
wall myself it's good I want to show you
something a lot of people in the room
you need more space
voila right into the wall wow sometimes
I will just stand here and watch
television for hours I love it
I love this TV oh and I also built this
table
what is that Chestnut no I think that is
either Pine or Nordic Cherry it's Pine
are we ready to sign some papers
actually no we have a couple of
questions uh about the neighborhood it's
it's very safe and very clean uh uh also
it's very accepting of all lifestyles
it's a very gay friendly neighborhood
oh good that's good
it's good to be a combinating of that
let's go check out the master bedroom
this my friends is the master bedroom
check out the cathedral ceilings those
are like 17 feet high we have cable
Readiness right there I'm going to
totally pimp this place out I'm going to
put a surround sound system I'm going to
put a plasma screen right against this
one I'm putting my bed right over here
no no no no no no this is a shared wall
neighbor throws his wife into the wall
plasma screen hits the floor totally
smashed well then I will get a warranty
don't come right bless her ripoff well
then I won't get a warrant so that's the
problem is solved
oh man
these babies are thin
so this is the master bedroom and these
walls they used to be like white like an
asylum so I wanted it to be softer so I
had it painted in eggshell white guess
what white and X real white are exactly
the same color
exactly so that you were going to tidy
things up well I on you
what a cute bench thanks that's my bed
Jan has uh some space issues so I curl
up on that puppy really because
seems pretty narrow and short it's
actually a lot bigger than it seems look
at this
quickly
so what do you say we get started after
breakfast I'm full
so how you feeling about the new company
I feel good wow
you excited about the new company yeah
I'm excited to start the company
Mr breakfast
we did that
so what's next
Michael just stop for a second
Michael stop for a second no I know you
are just let me have just give me fine
oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I can't do this
this is pathetic isn't it
I am such an idiot
I gave up the only job I ever loved to
do this
I beg in my Crocs
a week today
I felt much stronger yesterday
Mike Benjamin Button in Reverse you know
Michael when I feel overwhelmed I'm not
overwhelmed Pam I know no I'm saying
that when I feel overwhelmed something I
like to do is make a list
make a list of things to do
and then start with the easy stuff
whatever calms you down okay first
work out and Hey look you did that check
eat an enormous breakfast
check don't pay for a nice weekend and
then I just need you to sign here at
this era what kind of mortgage did you
get
uh tenure
well 10 over 30 so 30 year total what
what
you said ten
ten year fixed
over 30 30 or total oh 30 years okay
okay wow you'll be paying this off in
your mid 70s
forget about retiring when you're 65.
hey I've got an idea you know that extra
bedroom if the whole girlfriend thing
never happens that's where the nurse can
live okay
this is it whenever you're ready yeah
um
oh oh okay is that supposed to come off
hey look cool carpenter ants
um I'm gonna take a little uh breather
for a second excuse me it'll be here
waiting for you oh man
a 30-year mortgage at Michael's age
essentially means that he's buying a
coffin if I were buying my coffin I
would get one with thicker walls so you
couldn't hear the other dead people
oh whenever you're ready Michael oh
oh thank you you're welcome
I'm so so sorry for the temperature in
here
the um sliding glass door shattered
it's actually a really cute story do you
want to tell it babe or should I tell it
I don't like that story babe come on
it's a cute story Michael ran through
the sliding glass door because he
thought he heard the ice cream truck
stop it but I mean I like ice cream okay
sue me oh no don't I shouldn't say that
jokingly because she will sue me she
loves to sue she loves lawsuits you know
honey that door was extremely clean and
it looked invisible you are so right you
are so right because before I lived here
the glass was always covered in smudges
and then I moved in and I cleaned it so
I guess that makes me the devil
you are she is she is the devil I'm in
hell
I'm burning help me you shouldn't jump
about that the ceilings are lower than
they were last week that I don't I don't
know if you showed me this same unit or
not and Michael this is the unit where
are all the hot people I was told that
there would be all these attractive
singles and as far as I can tell I'm the
best looking person here there's a basic
principle in real estate that you should
never be the best looking person in the
development
it's sort of common sense because if you
are
then
you had no place to go but down
is this a financial thing if it's a
financial thing what some people do is
they rent out the third bedroom
I am not going to rent the third bedroom
I want a price reduction or I am a walk
you will lose seven thousand dollars if
you
I made a recession
I'm glad I find I'm a homeowner what
good to be a homeowner Diversified but
it's a good
this is fun we're having fun totally
having fun can you imagine those poor
saps stuck at the office today okay
okay all right
here we go
okay that's nice everybody enjoying
their meal
hey babe yeah how about we take the beer
sign down until our guests leave and
then we can discuss it no no
I'm gonna leave it up I think it ties
the whole room together
[Music]
Hunter's very talented
you know what
I don't think he's that good at least
he's an artist BFG I'm a screenwriter
and I'm a camera maker but y'all hear me
Brandon brag about it no all you do is
you get me to try to work on my rich
friends for an investment opportunity
man I would love to burn your candles
you burn it you buy it oh good I'll be
your first customer you're hardly by
first
[Music]
laughs
that is a two hundred dollar plasma
screen TV you just killed good luck
paying me back on your zero dollars a
year salary plus benefits babe